is not the criminal  her  allegations include several counts of  flying under the influence  swerving in the air was more like it  then he crashed hard into the dock and  tumbled spilled Rizzo's violet spectrum  but  last tip we got pointed toward the back  bays  you and about six other enterprising  maverick I do hope you're the lucky  hunter  and you see this man  aber from above what brings you to my  little moonlight Kingdom  listen to the fire those can alive or  dead rare  my flame yeah don't worry mr. McCready  we'll treat mr. Flicka I'll miss my baby  pyro but it beats losing my head  keen eyes you got there sunita gave me  this luck  lay it up  ship got impact that's burea  am i your dark reflect  you can come  dandy both words it's not  how goes the hunt  hum in room and nothing excessive mind  you  here's the bounty payout nice work down  there  [Music]  you